il dit alors votre fille julie et et
avec dice depuis 2014
oui elle est partie en novembre 2014
elle étudia l'étudiant d'allemagne c'est
ça alors elle était en prépa littéraire
à lille en fait elle faisait hypokhâgne
khâgne et hypokhâgne elle a eu
l'opportunité de faire un double cursus
pour les faire des études en allemagne
d'accord donc on est en 2011
en 2011 elle à elle a eu un de par sa
formation littéraire philosophique un
intérêt pour la religion musulmane
malheureusement elle est tombée sur des
personnes qui l'ont orienté vers une
idéologie radicale jihadistes et j'avais
bien remarqué à cette époque là un
changement dans son comportement est
quoi ce jour là où quand comment vous
avez remarquez bien remarqué au niveau
de la tenue vestimentaire elle partie à
l'intérieur les temps en internat il
partait le dimanche soir là le dimanche
soir elle rentrée le samedi midi et
j'avais remarqué quand elle rentrait sa
façon de s'habiller de ceux de ce mec
qui et comment
valls a veillé de beaucoup plus couverte
c'est une fille moderne à nos lecteurs
alors elle a été beaucoup plus couverte
elle de se maquiller plus il se ne se
fait piller s'épiler plus aussi et donc
elle a nous a appris sa conversion bon
c'était pas un programme mais nous nous
sommes moi je suis catholique mon mari
et protestants on a essayé d'argumenter
de voir un petit peu bas et là elle a
voulu changer de confession musulmane
ça a été des discussions avec son père
avec avec moi même et puis un jour quand
elle a appris son départ en allemagne
est la plus part des deux religions est
là
l afld elle a essayé de comment à dire
de faire en sorte qu'on se méfie pas
parce que ça fait qu'elle partait et
quatre mois après son arrivée en
allemagne on apprenait qu'elle avait
quitté l'université qu'elle se
retrouvait marié cultuellement avec un
un allemand converti qui n'était pas
musulman
d'accord j'ai retrouvé ma fille
complètement changé ma fille était en
billets en niqab un de la tête aux pieds
avec eux c'est dans ce jeu ne vous avait
prévenu avant ou un non pas du tout est
arrivé
vous avez été la voir en allemagne nous
on est allé la voir en allemagne on a
d'abord appris par sa colocataire
qu'elle partait qu'elle quittait sa
colocation pour vivre avec un allemand
donc quand j'ai retrouvé ma fille j'ai
retrouvé une personne qui n'était plus
ma fille c'était ma fille physiquement
mais avec des idées des prêt-à-penser
qui ne ressemblait pas à son ambition
cloud processus que vous décrivez c'est
quelqu'un qui la guide par exemple de
dissimuler à un moment c'est la toile
est sûre ça ferait théorie bien sûr que
quelqu'un qui la guident et a largement
règlement mais justement à je reviens de
justement qui la guide étape par étape
moi je voudrais bien le savoir
maintenant et a qu'une seule personne
qui pourra le faire c'est ma fille si
elle rentre et qu'elle ne veut pas la
soustraire à la justice
moi je vais vous la voler je ne sais pas
où elle est maintenant elle est
peut-être décédé je ne sais pas ça fait
trois mois que je n'ai plus de ces
nouvelles ni de mes petits fils je sais
je reviens je rejoins ce que vous lisiez
effectivement il ya des recruteurs qui
dans la région lilloise où orienter ma
fille vers un islam qui n'était pas
qu'ils étaient à un jeu idiot et la
liste qui n'était pas être l'islam
l'islamisme annonçant ces lycéens pour
eux j'ai simplement
une seule aux spiritualités pour
entraîner ses jeunes à partir et on est
en 2011 ne nous sommes pas méfiée on a
fait confiance à notre si elle est parti
là bas en allemagne et nous nous avons
découvert ça a pris dix oui quelles sont
les dernières nouvelles que vous avez eu
votre fille les dernières nouvelles
c'est ya trois mois elle était dans la
région de deir ezzor
donc le dernier bastion où c'est quand
le sud est de la syrie encore elle
voulait rentrer elle me disais je veux
partir je veux quand je veux quitter cet
endroit là je regrette qu'elle
regrettait de tout à fait ah oui et vous
non plus vous n'avez plus de nouvelles
elle regrettait d'être parti mais elle
était entourée de kurdes de la coalition
internationale les étés il n'avait plus
de deux commandes alimentaire
d'alimentation il y avait un blocus
donc elle ne s'était plus nourris qui
commençait à être bombardées donc voilà
elles sont et est rentrée elle regretté
d'être partir les mamans elle a des
enfants là bas elle a eu un enfant en
allemagne a eu des enfants ont
effectivement en syrie également
elle est partie avec son compagnon elle
est partie avec son mari gagnant malgré
le signalement que j'ai fait trois mois
avant je tiens à le préciser vous qui
avez su aller à la justice et des signes
à la justice française effectivement
parce que j'ai vu que ça allait un peu
trop loin
un grand en l'ayant vu la dernière fois
en août 2014
elle était j'ai fait un signalement les
autorités françaises se sont rapprochés
des autorités allemandes et on a
confirmé que le compagnon de ma fille
elle avait épousé était surveillée
depuis deux ans par les autorités
allemandes et qu'elle était dans une
mouvance salafiste radical et nous on is
on ne le savait pas on y aller
régulièrement personne ne nous a averti
aujourd'hui vous avez envie de le
retrouver votre fille bien sûr j'avais
encore de laisser ma fille je garde
l'espoir qu'elles puissent être parmi
les 130 djihadistes qui vont rentrer que
mes petits enfants se trouvaient parmi
ces
parce que les enfants n'ont rien demandé
je rejoins ce que vous aviez dit ils
n'ont rien demandé ni mes enfants ils
n'ont pas demandé à naître là bas ni à
partir là bas avec leur forcément vous
êtes pour donc le rapatriement des
étudiants des sam est désormais
réellement vous vous espérez voilà
retrouvez votre fille et je veux pas la
tendance à la justice
cet accord a témoigné dans ce sens ça
c'est vous qui l'avez vous qui l'avez
signalé
je vous laisse les allégés ou là
transparent depuis quatre ans j'ai donné
toutes les informations que j'avais sur
ma fille à chaque fois à aux autorités a
donc voilà j'ai eu l'impression de même
de la dénoncer je pensais qu'à la
dénonçant ça le ferait pour sambi pour
son bien effectivement et elle est
partie quand même 1 2 malgré ce
signalement alors lydie merci pour votre
témoignage